DreamWorks presents How to Train Your
Dragon how to find the hidden world
what's outer lunch first learn the
legend out there beyond the edge of the
world lies the home of the dragon and I
believe this your destiny go find this
head what are you gonna do about it
suit up gang your team hang on tight
discover a world of mystery and Wonder
now back the king just don't get caught
this year
once you've seen the human world
nothing will ever be the same again
DreamWorks How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden work this is Berk son it was the
home of your grandparents and your
grandparents before then but out there
beyond the age of the world why is the
home of the Dragons
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you don't know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up he's not the only one
[Music]
another Night Fury lady she's more like
a right I'm night hearing yeah yours is
better probably there is an armada with
enough cages for all of our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden world I wouldn't destroy
everything you rely
you're nothing without your dragon
if primo succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up game we have one shot a thing
you try to baby to a battle I couldn't
find a sitter
and hit it morals have really touched
that's the key
right but inside
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]
[Music]